it's milli ten o'clock when many hotel
guys will be stinking up heading to bed
but the music concert is just about to
start we've been doing this for twenty
years we've been playing music I think
Goods gonna like
[Music]
and
I don't do drugs I've never thought I'd
see a dancing mushroom but I was wrong
[Music]
it's like a Summer of Love these people
are weird but they sure are friendly
it's a dream it's really happening
are you checking in behind you here it's
insane how guests are trying to check in
over this racket if I have arrived to
this I would have gotten on the first
plane back home I don't think I'll be
able to relax here Wow and the longer
the music goes on the more guests
complain
you know what it's on me tonight okay
we're going to make me happy no matter
what okay all right with Joanna giving
away women for free the lodge is losing
money pushing this hotel further into
debt it make against so much remember
politics it's way past midnight and with
the families finally wrapping up it's
time for me to get some sleep before I
dive under those colors I'm dying to see
what's on top of them that is disgusting
I am NOT putting my head on that pillow
ah I just touched that it's like a
mosaic I'm seaman look at that
disgusting look at the lampshade
look at that actually challenge money
for people to sleep in this filth wow
this is definitely a knife my sleeping
bag all right myself I try to burn my
truck
[Music]
excavators
[Music]
[Applause]